alors je vais vous dire on va faire
jouer lire un grand concours de lancer
de noyaux de cerises est le grand
gagnant gagnera une boîte de mon chéri
vient de trouver le truc hein merci
super sur le gâteau c'est un super
cadeau alors ce que je propose c'est
patrick déjà on va essayer de le faire
nous oui et après toi tu va nous montrer
parce que voilà toi tu vas 13 mètres un
record mais n'amélioraient dès que mon
corps alors on va essayer
allez vous allez tous le faire chacun
motorola qui est le meilleur
patrick est ce que tu peux d'abord
expliquer aux téléspectateurs dont la
technique nous alors on se met comme ça
sans lancer alors tu peux m'améliorer là
où le décor est là le départ élaboré la
mode et la n ya pas d rien on peut avoir
le balancer du corps mais on n'avance
pas et la plupart mariées bac à sable
montfermeil faucons à séreilhac agréable
non meublé chéri vous démarrez là c'est
là qu'on a dit on a dit on a démarré
alors attention on va démarrer avec mes
tenues talent et on va démarrer avec
gilbert d allah j'ai appelé mon ami m'a
dit j'ai été le meilleur qu il
après bernard montiel m'a dit allez
vas-y au mans s'est bien préparé les
commence à aller voter c'est parti banny
ne la font pas dans la gueule à temps
attendez il a fait pièce il avait sept
mètres 50 morts franchement il est très
fort mais attention bernard montiel
attention bernard montiel brigitte macro
moore garde ce serait mon attention on y
va à l'évasion berlin
aulas maintenant s'il a fait même pas 3
méfiez vous allez très salée vas-y -
keystone en phase i maschi vous allez
voir le champion vous allez voir vous
allez voir comment ça pas vous mettre
dans le cerceau machin dans le cerceau
eh les gars regarde sur la tête de ma
mère au départ d'el fois laurence déjà
bien sûr qu'on peut parler voyons dans
les noyaux temps après par le cd pas ta
mère na waie c'est pas mal non mais
prends tu la mise à tomber face à
l'impact il a non non non non la bad a
raison ça n'impacte pas la salle un pack
wii la réponse à la pagode héros adoré
me tient à laisser partir
allez raymond on va voir pour la sto
gilles verdez excellent en lancer noyaux
de cerises
c'est un truc de fou de bonheur d'avoir
le joyau brûlures il demeure toutefois
l'habitude de cracher raymond six mois
six mètres mais la chine est géré mon
record pour l'instant allez-y même si à
la base sous traitance a fait crisser
d'y aller taddei
les gardes mobiles et la cabine et la
cmr attendez attendez mais qu'est-ce
qu'on n'a pas trouvé quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas trouvé votre fonction de ça on
veut retirer à la fin parce que je crois
en fait partie du champ plus haut niveau
à castaldi avait des gens de manifs il a
pris un ascendant avec moyens sous la
jupe après de très belles gens me
croisent devant deux ans devant les
branchements pour nîmes à kelly mais
d'aurélie sauve nous vous avez compris
de jeu pourquoi je ne comprendrais pas
allez on y va
les boutiques et 10,9 en ratant son
alors attendez attendez je vous alors je
voulais te dire un truc je vais vous
dire un truc
celui qui aura le moins bon noyau dur
rien alors à déguiser jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission en cerise de groupama
je n'en sais rien c'est d'abord la
matmut dont la brasse également d'axa
voilà donc allez-y la vallée
à laval et se prend pour qui
pas mal c'est la première défi pour
l'instant on y va l'attentât qui vise à
y est allé d'une belle et bonne avance
au badminton pensons pas que des filles
le dsce compte la soirée mais si vous
avez enlevé dans ce qu'il dit il va
pouvoir
allez on y va aller pour le départ je
n'ai pas marqué sur le départ à georges
doumit vas-y il va et parce que lui le
banquier
oui et professionnels j'aime bien
fonctionné qu'est ce qu'il en pense pour
l'instant patrick c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal à le faire après avoir
patrouillé dans l'eau et là vous allez
prendre un coup dans la dans la carafe
c'est qu'il faut venir et légaux
laurence boccolini qu il dit il a pressé
sur moi et a écrit des la technique
départ c'est d'abord mais lloris épatant
pétanque et l'autre comme ça c'est pas
le cochonnet
il est très fort ouais l'égalité bon
choix est très bon en même temps là les
cherry on a notre shopping tu fais
matthieu dugal d'ananas temps qu'on a
droit à une deuxième alors à temps non
parce que lui l'avait gens il ne veut
pas faire tout ce que nous sommes en
accord
donc la durée de la bouche ont tout
lâché bois dès l'embauché banal même pas
du tout l'esprit saint jean la mâchoire
carrée de fitch est vrai qu'on est là
sur game numéro est plus de 6 m pour
mature croyable olalala avec hélas il a
dû en donnant dénoyautées des lacs et
des plaisirs masri d'accord les a prises
avec l'accueil des cerises o'neal va
fermer remettre à temps c'est pas de
leur mort tu vas vers lui m mais je suis
le titre moi j'aime pas eu avec ma
langue tamoule quoi tu peux tu réussis
le fayot et depuis lancé
lemonade et la salive et moi je déteste
ça sourit jean miroite faut lever les
mains d'un seul alors attention voilà la
mède c'est donc il avait l'outil sera en
cerise de groupama
ouais c'est bien puisque vous avez mis
la même tenue que hier vous pouvez vous
les récoltes agricoles et maintenant
vous allez voir patrie la photo ni
patrick anthony c'est le choco france
away du lancer de noyaux de cerises non
mais pardon pardon il est là son noyau
depuis une heure c'est croire pourquoi
alors mais n'en voyons pas ce qu'il
avait une surprise il a toujours une
solution
c'est normal les champions du monde
français champion du monde de némo venba
les patrons des champions 2-0 luca
patrick oui tu fais quoi
sinon à part ça je suis fonctionnaire
d'accord voilà de quoi non mairie will
atenton sont d'accord patrick sais pas
si tu veux mais tu as coup de boule
non non ça c'est moche alors patrick tu
fais 13 mètres et servir au séton record
13 et oui vous allez voir le nom à lyon
va partir le noyau va partir et quand ça
va partir
je veux vous dire ça va partir c'est
qu'ils vont pouvoir appeler ta technique
donc tu te mets comme ceci oui et donc
après en coupe boule voilà coup de
l'accord tu veux que je te mets mathieu
devant toi pathé ou mathieu
[Applaudissements]
il a fait combien d être enchaînés allez
vous pouvez les enchaîner oui ça c'est
pas non plus très physique qui n'est pas
la question de kaniv et nos bénévoles
chine est ce qu'on peut et est ce que
vous faites les enchaîner seul hic elle
croit que c'est tellement physique qu'il
faut que je vais me coucher la vienne
j'ai bossé et loyaux tuerie écoutez
gentil tu lui on entends tu as couché
bras c'est bon là ça va quoi tu vois
même pas partir le noyau alors c'est
parti
animateur de noms sur le deuxième on est
fatigué d'être la langue se fatiguent
non merci pas comme les noyaux sont très
gros des droits des petits voyous les
sorties aussi
ah ouais mais bon c'est vrai ça va
lancer les muscles le plan il semble
vraiment comme la langue c'est aussi ça
la réponse à l'énerver
[Rires]